зараз друзі на глибинних у нас 2000
cypher знаєш чого платформою масивного
Петро i make me на світлових подати ефір я
її модератор володимир страшенно раді вас
всіх вигляд від і продати його і гарди що
дня у нас сьогодні люди на цю вже бачили
і вичавлював з можуть надходити від світла
продатися Юлія приводу психолог то
експерт , інший наприклад актуальних
для всіх нас я ніби нормальному та
нативному стані Юлія vito і вас
добрий вечір добрий вечір дорогі друзі
я всіх рада відчувати чути бачити і
вас знайти
дізнаємось юля ну давай місця в кар'єр будемо
відразу пачино та історія така як у
хотів сьогодні поговорити ось уже більше
не два місяці крива видно облік там
шок ми здавалося двадцятом з вами в тому
локкер проти
but i bought і в нормальному усуненні
панічні атаки нуцці ж у принципі
пройшло за важливих лише низьких українців і
блюдо я нехай адаптувалася позичити а
я живу зараз роблять це ви якась
дикун як душа такого психа логічних
ефективніше konami далі фракції
людині але скажемо а так роблять ви
виглядаю зовсім нічого навідуються і
навіть частують ці люди ці приймають
важливі рішення і для них у них не карти
не світу ми вже там про могла б видно в
дружини травня чому там ще один і травня білик і
його місяць у Києві означає посиланням
ресторану просити cafe-cafe процідити
адже вона моя дружина моя блокпосте інша
історія з любеку здається все зникло та
на можна дозволяє особини
наприклад by чого ти пазу ти мені емоції
тому що там хто види вина та люди
повернути і так далі до кінця та третя
група людей царю даяки пожинають свою ну
напевно скрізь росіян можна сказати
засудили мулати на українців
тобто ви нам його потрібно може
дотягнутися до russian вона може бути
всередині сюди своїх спину мадам піке за
кого голосувала б назвав і бла бла бла
бла ну до чого я замовлю до того що ось
налаштувань сусп лист і душить трансформайс
складу куди кого звана
стикалася де люди думала як вичавлений
а у
них від і всередині мати травму. зірка
психологією акції можна за ясною тут я
ваще
класична ситуація
абсолютно класична справа в тому, що
історія розвивається по спіралі і якщо
прочитати будь-яку історію
ретроспективу в будь-якій війні то люди хоча
ми живемо 21 столітті а це було наприклад
двадцятому дев'ятнадцятому
середні віки загалом люди поводилися
приблизно однаково це називається
людський фактор тобто ми не
змінилися наші геноми наша поведінка
змінилося дуже мало найголовніше
ось основна складова яка більше
всього впливає на психіку відсутність
безпеки ризики дивно те що
раціональне мислення має дуже мале
ставлення насправді до уникнення
небезпеки всі ми на сьогоднішній день у
нас на україні
частково в інших країнах мали та не
наших співгромадян а люди наприклад там теж
молдова де я була, а потім поверталася
знову їздила туди у мене там мої
пацієнти ось вони теж надзвичайно
боятися і вже сьогодні
загальна категорія тобто більшість
людей мислить виключно
емоційно тобто коли ми
орієнтовані на ризик, коли ми знаходимося
у ній безпеки ми ніколи не мислимо
раціонально ми мислимо емоційно це
перша велика проблема людський
фактор
ще перед війною я брала участь у
конференції хижаків вони періодично
запрошують психолога вайда загальносвітова
конференція була і брала участь ніяк
спікер а як слухачів був дуже
цікаво послухай навіть скажемо зараз
з'являється якийсь новий дуже
коротко про це скажу просто щоб
далі йти вже в нашій бесіді так от
найрозумніші люди світу дійсно
найрозумніші в основному це америка.
Європа ізраїль південна африка там теж з
дуже толково люди які на ти з
штучним інтелектом
визначає наше майбутнє як нескінченно
стабільна диктатура
штучного інтелекту правити та
нескінченно стабільна диктатура це
відсутність емоцій
відсутність емоційних рішень
ця відсутність
природи людини мислити та реагувати
на ризик та на колосальну небезпеку
емоційно саме тому люди там
ведуть себе в паніці, причому володар не
будемо зваблюватися ми з вами точно так само
як кажуть ми стару буває проруха
або загалом шевець ми всі однакові по
цьому ось ці нескінченно стабільні
диктатури це наше майбутнє коли
штучний інтелект
саморозвиваючий буде керувати нами
таки не впорався зі своїми емоціями
я це говорю не для того, щоб зараз
давати якісь характеристики я сама
така ми все таки і ми всі люди і в
уряді теж люди хоч по великому
рахунку виграють ті країни, де
ще задовго до
штучного інтелекту і ось цих
нескінченно стабільних диктатур був дуже
такий
я б сказала фільтраційний підхід до
тому якою буде державна
програма хто нами керуватиме і так
далі ну а у них там не бро
навіть швейцарія ще кілька країн ми
живемо у чудовій країні і як показує
практика у нас чудові люди навіть я не
очікувала що ми будемо такі сильні та так
згрупований але час іде
людина будь він в уряді будь він
звичайний громадини проте
починаємо втомлюватися навіть великий
фрейд свого часу визначить так
званої психологічні захисту то для
щоб мозок не
не перевтомився до тієї стадії, коли
доведеться відкривати польові шпиталі так
свого часу припускали до виду і
класти туди людей із колосальним
емоційним виснаженням коли вже не
руки не ноги не рухаються тому мозок
включає основні дві психологічні
захисту це заперечення все вже нічого немає
вигнали я хоч трохи ось тут уже
поживу на інформацію дивитимусь
крізь пальці та і
раціоналізація заперечують зазвичай люди
які мало взагалі падають ситуацію
аналізу але це так
б'ють біги дають бери ось є люди
які функціонують дуже таким я б
сказала миттєво реактивним способом
є ось цей стимул реакції не
вклинююсь між ось цими двома
категоріями зі своїм аналізом яких
таких людей досить багато, тому що
вони як кажуть на друга і вчилися в
школі цього не вчать і є другою
варіант
реагування чи вірніше є другий
варіант реагування під прикриттям
психологічного захисту
називається раціоналізації це люди більше
аналітичного складу
вони є в уряді вони є і в
економіці в економічній сфері вони є
і там де не знаю сфера краси тобто
ви знаєте вони скидами немає такого щоб
елітарний уряд всі інші
там зміни немає ми не в середні віки жидам
у нас досить багато інтелектуальних
людей які займаються роботою який
їм подобається так ось вони зараз чи ми з
вами тому, що я підводжу під цю
категорію і себе, і вас ми починаємо
раціоналізувати ми маючи минулий досвід
намагаємося створити картину майбутнього і на
сьогоднішній день якщо у певної
категорії паніки або людей з
певною структурою нервової системи
там де все зникло і насправді
війна а я працюю з такими людьми це
моя основна категорія моїх пацієнтів
це люди, які живуть у важких неврозах
страху
обсесивно-компульсивних розладах з
нав'язливими думками з постійними країнами
onvif лобі та
депресії ці люди взагалі всі
сприймають у темному світлі та їх потрібно
якимось чином підбадьорювати самими
великими істинами що це не назавжди
що ви райд величезна ймовірність
велика ймовірність хоч звичайно у
загалом то в людській природі ось
перечитую книгу на симатта або
українською він міг би огляд вони б
підковістю ось просто як причетно я
дуже люблю читати українською але
зазвичай консультую російською по
звичці що все життя майже більше 25
років термінологія знаєте хоч будемо
переходити на українську ось випадок так
тобто взагалі
дуже багато випадковостей у житті тому
як кажуть чек припускає бог
має в своєму розпорядженні але кінця світу не
передбачається тому ось людям з
негативним таким мисленням
звичайно потрібно визначати та розповідати
що загалом подивіться весь світ за нас
люди які починають раціоналізувати
і взагалі забуває чи навпаки витісняти
заперечувати izabo це війні вона
продовжується і вже чомусь починається
якісь справді дивні поділки
або якісь дивні розмови ні про що
я пляж процент я сказав тоді тургун c6
просто грузинів
владимир це так але все ж таки судячи тому
як нас контролює євро вона
контролює ми на передовий але спілкуючись
з моїми колегами по всьому світу народ
переляканий і дуже напружений у будь-якому
випадку люди
бояться ядерного боятися, бо вже
колись була карибська криза і справа
підійшло практично це я зараз говорю
не про психологічні речі, а загальний
людських, але я як психолог не можу
їх ігнорувати то зараз знову
колосальна криза та народ боїться і нас
стримують тому я впевнена що ті хто
зараз біля керма
навіть за якихось таких ось зовнішніх
проявах іноді там
розлийся море шапками закидаємо або
навпаки з іншого стоїть ось ці
суперечливі
деякі інформаційні моменти ну вони
все одно контролюються зараз усім
світом тому я все-таки розраховую на
спільні розсудливість тих хто за ним
варто атакують
називали те на знаю я як
приступити всю історію США і різьблені
реакції на стрес і придушать привали в
годині від цін прибирали душ відривала це
мудаки люди про втрачену ранку цінно
за ват і обидва вважають просто роботою
утворюється але може а жучок шавка або
стріляються на газ яка потребного
животи ніхто не стріляє впевненими травня
у пляшечку з кліматом закривши все -
добрі жеру своїм дітям цпш інша
історія що на показує і про со
середньої
інтелект штучний інтелект на пвх
систему
стримувань і противаг я хто вкаже до
досі вона готова щоб не називати
емотивним фактором мабуть у прийнятті
рішення
тільки я дозволю в боці піддавайтеся а ось
я качок ми приймали рішення вимкнений та
раціонально туди прямий українці та спрутів
набити на нього тут але які тут
раціональний аромат країни за ядерну
оружня і там значно беша армія під вечерю
що нижче новинам ресурс на бази як що
брата вимкнена українця так точно
більше я наношу воювати високу але я
показала нам за фігню партнери d3 прийду
би там чистики нам топку нагадай мені
запали можна сказати дуже раціональні
рішення на і красивим рішенням тут все
роки так само як і ми з вами та нашим
біди чим seen at the top Туреччина
нормально серце руці і правильно
абсолютно правильно тому світ дуальний
життя дуальне єдність протиріч
абсолютно з вами згодна я хочу
ось зараз ось ще доповнити один такий
момент і зараз багато читай автором
яка
скажімо так і не дуже актуальна на
сьогоднішній день і ось був дуже
відомий Даниїл гранін він дуже довго
жив і дуже довго писала час це
письменник радянський, але дуже такий знаєте
совість нації такі теж були тоді він
багато писав і науки тому я із сім'ї
вчених тому я його впізнав вічно так
ось він говорив абсолютно атеїстичний
налаштована людина
минулі всю війну та свій час
виступали перед бундестагом вже через
30 або там 35 або через 40 років
розповідали про війну Другої світової та
великою вітчизняною
жах ці хворі для того щоб не з
вже діти та онуки тих хто
пішов війною
переоцінили та ще раз оцінили цю
ситуацію під до він багато він писав про війну
то під він казав що
дивним чином але на боці тих
хто захищати себе бог ну ось завжди ось
як би там не було, ось навіть тоді був
якийсь дивний перелом можна назвати
його абсолютно це атеїстичні
налаштований катара спілкувався у своє
час із найголовнішими воєначальниками
говорили про з дійсної допомоги
вищих сил на сьогодні це
сприймається як ми якийсь
енергетичний потенціал так ось у нас
взагалі те, що відбувається чистота
яке я дивлюся ось наскільки чисто і
зараз україна миють чистять висаджують
квіти ось енергетика
те, що зараз відбувається при всіх
нюансах скажемо так по-різному
хтось уже одним належать до даності
чином хтось іншим і тим не менш
енергетика перемоги відчувається ось і
багато хто відчуває ті хто сюди приїжджає
це безумовно не може не тішити хоч
про те, що йде війна, забувати звичайно
ні ось я хотів би з вами детально
розібратися ден формованих чи так вже
момент вже набридне покаються сублімація
змиву накочував своїх емоцій
всієї всієї палітри церкви трохи iv на
своїх євромайдан ну ну ну там ви готові
звал зануритися у ви не ну і центр але я
не буду там точно ось цьому серцю
живе авіком 80 на літр вухо та
тому тому ви так уже не в тому ну і
там водиться так то просто але я кричав
гей можна було повноцінно збер тату важливі
abcd
шабельник і викликаю ну просто такі
мови любиш нас такого горіть ти
розумієш що ти точно тут новачок і ви
нам кому точно путін там та й що з ними
алі точному українці харчування чуму така
сублімація за розвивається ось яка і
природа і шору б ти я що тобі такий
говорять, а як же звичайно поясню це теж
дуже відомий феномен але і вона в тому
що страх який лежить в основі всього
війна це завжди 100 країн за власне
життя за життя близькі довго відчувати
страх практично не реальна людина
виснажується організм сам мозок сам
починає продукувати
похідні тобто міняти країн на
якісь інші почуття емоції як
правило це або агресія на інших або
аутоагресія з виникненням провини та
тривоги
тривога таке ж неприємне почуття
багато чутливих людей і навіть не
дуже чутлива на сьогоднішній день
ось
повітряна тривога та тобто як тільки
виникають у нас усіх на телефонах стоїть
те, що зараз потрібно бігти ляльці кити
боголюдини ось тільки що він там
щось робив сміявся та робили
розмовляв по телефону та накрила
тривога теж вкрай вимотують
стані
мозок
воліє або агресію або вино
вина такий феномен ось це я ось якраз
зовсім не дано проводила ефір він вінні
що вижив дали синдром, що вижив ось це
саме власне основна складова
це біна але будь-яка людина що
свідомо та несвідомо
починає відчувати провину, а як правило
жертви причому навіть якщо це жертвою
мимоволі тобто на нас напали ми
опинилися у жертовному становищі ми не
є жертвами
але ми опинилися у такому становищі ми
змушені перебувати чат у такому
стані хтось змушений їдучи з
дітьми зі старими хтось змушений
через обставини перебувати тут а
ось ця вимушеність вона завжди
визначає жертовність так ось ще
відомі всім трикутник картону це
вина потім вірніше жертва інтернету вина
жертва потім рятувальник у нас хват
вистачало сил допомогти іншим допомагати
іншим ми відчували що ми коли
допомагаємо іншим ми виходимо з цього
жертовного стану але ж ми залишаємося
все одно в цьому невротичному
трикутники тому що ми ніяк не
компенсуємо травму вени яка до
жаль я як фахівець працюючий з
цим вже тобто я розраховувала на те
що вона як ми всі завжди розраховуємо
на краще виходить залежно від
обставин і ця травма вже очевидна і
посттравматичний розлад
вже загалом набирає свої оберти знову
ж у певних категоріях у
певному відсотковому відношенні та тим
не менш і так ми рятуємо але поступово
втомлюємося тому що це все ще
невротичних ось ми кидаємося рятувати
щоб трохи відлягло в нас від душі
піти в будь-якому випадку зараз на допомогу
людей, які важко стали, це важка допомога
і потім рано чи пізно настає
класичний стан переслідувача до
росіян ми ніяк не зможемо дістатися
Бувай
ми можемо лише влаштовувати якісь
дебати абсолютно марна і тому що
там хто хотів уже давно зрозумів це
зрозуміло це не тема наші зараз нашого
спілкування, проте на кого можна
накинутися на своїх і це не в
у разі без своїх щоб чужі боялися ні
це просто спроба знайти когось на кого
би можна було злити роздратування ось той
пам'ятайте тріска і почала стимул та реакція
загальна мені ситуація стимулює людина
його просто розриваючи і
реакція миттєво скинути напругу
фрейд знову ж звернуся до нього колись
сказав що принцип біологічної
людського життя, а ми з вами
Абсолютна однаково про цей план
ухиляння від напруги якщо не піти прийде
хвороба люди рятують себе рятуються тим
що намагаються скинути напругу до
жаль у нас поки що та й у всьому світі
владимир я не знаю таких служб, але хіба
що ізраїль великі молодці але не всі
час ось в ізраїлі та то миттєво якщо
починається якийсь цукерок
психологічний літер або якісь
проблеми психологічні служби їх
величезна кількість вони розуміють чим вони
мають справу ми до вперше зіткнулися так
є ряд фахівців які працюють з
посттравматичним стресовим
розладом але це дуже
незначна кількість людей це що
пропонується часто та багато пропонується
як психологічний вихід не зовсім
відповідає саме цій проблематиці
тому люди кидаються на своїх справу в
тому що навіть після ось такого
до після такої реакції знову підемо
назад у петрук бо розумне
чутливе освічені люди
розуміють що кидатися на ту, хто вивезла
там дитину або хто може бути ні
зовсім так мислить чи хтось вийшов конфлікт
кави ну я наводжу дуже банально приклади
проте безглуздо тому що
ми всі підводні човни це лихо це або
колосальна біда нас усіх і загалом
просто що в залежності від
обставин
хтось переживає одним чином, а хтось
іншим ось таким чином вона
працює
ще раз попалася розлученням дарвіном цін
на
[музика]
ринках ну windom волонтера тобі
що вказала то я помічаю що серед
волонтерів дружба відразу нормативного
брехня склад
робота треба я можу на збираєшся і навіть
молодий масивний план і надоїв вух
ну ти відразу мило знищені можеш там
два три п'ять місяців ми ніби там
свої подушки цьому bespeco рано групізму
починаю хімікати, papers to draw це
просто в тому лише ся і з тобі трохи
оправи на проекту ви здається що я школи
він лайн не можемо і виходить ашшура денні
б з робите лагуна 1 робот вин позавчора
що дуже важливо так раз захід дати для
себе ось я покаже йому жвавість та емоції
куди сидить і ну обидва зарядитеся а там
пітирим погуляти і не знаю спортом
зайнятість із друзями street is a doctor
елемента мінімальні масивні такий
спроби десь сама
ти лише тофу і шостим що ну луківок їх
можна його на так направлю назвати
починається я кровотік то на приходиш на
комунікацію форматі ти дурень немає дідур
від нас аж контрпродуктивно правда є
глибоку поясну ось і як виклик
здебільшого навряд чи буду
простатектомія з і хочеш свою просити
оправи над амброю очей ти на мент докір
права нового
ви знаєте дуже чіткого від конкретного
відповіді немає в залежності від ситуації я
давно працюю
психіатричної клініки та дуже часто
стикаюся з
абсолютно різними реакціями на мене моїх
пацієнтів різними я розумію, що ці люди
у них проблеми які я лікую я
розумію, що по-іншому вони зараз не
можуть але я жива людина іноді у мене
ось тут у неї стимул-реакція зовнішні
обставини реакція раптом піднімається
але я навчилася це те, що я рекомендую
всім втиснутися киснути своє я свій хоча
б мікро аналіз ситуації між стимулом
і реакцією від реагувати в контексті
ситуації
звичайно, якщо вас збираються бити потрібно
або захищатися або все-таки людину
трішки обложити але якщо ви бачите
практично людиною істерики тому
що він втомився і він його нервова система не
справляється набагато більше ніж наприклад
паша тут найголовніше ось як
спілкуватися потрібно з такою людиною перше
не наближатися фізично близько
відійдіть він на вас, а ви трохи тільки
не задкувати а просто трохи відійти ні в
у разі не підключатися не так
агресії не на страх і точок якщо він
нормально нічого вам не зробить він
просто скидає негатив якщо ви
трохи відійдете на вас не потрапить ні
у жодному разі не треба переконувати я тебе
розумію тому що це тільки
психотерапевти вміють загалом десь
правильно ставити, а якщо просто звичайний
людина іншій людині починає
говорити про те, що так я тебе розумію так
ще розважливо ось тут можна в меню
отримати потрібно
просто чисто вибачте за сленг
інтуїтивно
просто не підключиться і навіть може бути
десь підтримати цю людину що ти
знаєш у мене тобто ти мене ось зараз
хочеш чимось звинуватити вони лише вчора
хотів звинуватити когось іншого та ми всі
тут як у банку ми всі тут як
підводні човни розумію тебе в тебе є
до мене претензії у мене їхнім іншим людям
треба нічого не вирішить, тому що ми
можемо зробити або посваритися зараз або
просто якось відреагувати на це і
жити далі тобто ось такий собі
резонуючий так
але тільки не підсилюють оскарі
резонують здоровому глузду
щоб виходило для того щоб
трохи ось вийти з тієї важкої важко
емоційна ситуація ось на мій погляд
є чотири кроки або 400 речі ось у тих
у кого є вина у кого є агресія у
кого загалом є щось будь-яка емоція
від розпачу і до зневіри і до ненависті
до всього світу ось
практично кожен з нас якщо ні
психіатрії може проаналізувати хоча
б трохи ситуацію на тут і зараз і
на якихось два кроки вперед того є
чотири дуже такі конкретні кроки я б
сказав це перше розібратися у причинах
того що відбувається чому він напав або
там чому там вона чому я так
відреагував коли починається
міркування та частина яка відповідає за
якщо він включається обов'язково дасть відповідь
принаймні це зніме напругу у
вас і вже коли інша людина вам спину
буде говорити та не пішов би ти такий
перед такою це вже сприйматиметься
ну як якийсь окремий випадок з іншим у
якого здали нерви буває та у людей
здають нерви ми ж ми всі люди колись
може здати в нас тобто розібратися в
причин просто включити на ось на цей
питання чому так відбувається розібратися
у собі наскільки я втомився чи втомилася
наскільки у мене емоційне вигоряння
скільки я ще зможу займатися
волонтерством як взагалі чомусь зі мною
це відбувається можливо мені потрібно відійти
убік можливо у мене почалися
якісь страхи чи якісь внутрішні
процеси які я дуже довго в собі та
тиснув загалом розібратися в тому що
відбувається навіть тим зародковий
психологічних знань а останні роки
психологів було стільки тренінгом ви
читали мільйони книг
розібратися можна далі богом за за
два тижні почни заробляти до двох
тисяч доларів консультуючи людей
побачиш процедур
ну тобто якихось елементарних
психологічних знань вистачить на те
щоб зрозуміти що в мене я дуже боюся
я дійсно почуваюся винним
Першого попелиці я ні не винен ця ситуація
провокує в мені мою провину, бо я
де і хронічно виховувався як
людина, яка за все у відповіді отримала
двійку і навар розвинув винний і так
далі тому, що були певні
сценарії тому що я дуже
чутлива людина я завжди беру на
себе тому, що в мене вкрай емпатія і
якщо хтось на мене косо подивився я вже
відчуваю що я є деякі
Причини розібратися в собі це
друге та третє це дійсно
зайнятися справою, яка не виснажує до
останнього ось я зараз можу приймати
не всіх пацієнтів у мирний час у мене
іноді бували нон-стоп 12 годин мозок
плавився але я знайти на автопілоті але я
могла там ось якісь такі базові
реперні
моменти людині дати а ось зараз щоб
не лягти також психіатричній клініці
все-таки тому що треба працюйте треба
жити і я в себе теж є про себе потрібно
дбати і я вже розумію що ось я це
можу, а це не можу принаймні
зараз і ви знаєте немає жодного почуття
провини немає ось тому що розібравшись у
причинах їх собі я це роблю постійно
немає я не допускаю хоча я дуже схильна
до мене мене так виховали я в сім'ї
православних священиків народилася там
все гріх і всі вина тому я це на
власної шкіри говориться і
4 надзвичайно важливі організм не
справляється також як і мозок а тіло і
мозок дуже пов'язані навіть якщо
тілу щось не подобається вона буде діод
надзвичайно втома вона смикатиме
головний комп'ютер цей комп'ютер буде
давати збій буде агресія вина
буде втома буде нервове виснаження
все буде тому навіть через не хочу
займатися з собою та самий може бути
важкий момент коли треба важкий аміду
волонтерстві коли величезна кількість
людей потребують нашої допомоги випити
кави вийти на вулицю постояти 10 хвилин
десь там на під променями сонця я добре
пам'ятаю як я просто для себе переїжджаючи з
однієї вклейки іншу вершину мене
запрошували то в одну то іншу для
консультування на аутсорс і де я
обов'язково заїжджала до улюбленого кафе
випити
капучино з круасан, а тому що я
розумієш якщо я цього не зроблю я
приїду я ризикнув робота буде не те
результат буде на 70 відсотків меншим
тобто обов'язково про себе хоч якось
подбати поряд з у нас
у нашому мікрорайоні дуже багато лікарів та
я бачу як вони ну в знайомій моїй ранку
хто футбол трохи щоб потім на
роботу хто в чомусь підтримує
себе на здоров'я тіла для того, щоб
потім коефіцієнт корисної дії був
на тій висоті щоб допомогти собі та
більшій кількості людей ось ці чотири
складові на ці складові
здатна будь-яка людина навіть хто закінчив
3 класи церковно-парафіяльної школи будь-якої
я б ніколи так консультувала моєї
клініці сани пара які але я так
розумію в принципі ніколи не хотів
вчитися, але в нього його покинула дівчина і
він дуже переживав і він не розповів
нічого не досягнете тому що я ні
ніде не прочитав чи не треба зараз
багато хто не вважає і тим не менш ось те
про що я кажу це будь-який може вище за
великому рахунку
ерудованість освіченість це не
має жодного значення наскільки
людина може підтримати себе побутова
мудрість
у мене бабуся моя двоюрідна навіть
пристік ставила замість підпису але вона
була надзвичайно мудрою на невміле ні
читати ні писати не закінчував і що було
надзвичайно мудро та вміло себе допомогти
померла у 90 вісім років так що ось
Володимир ось ось так потрібно зараз ось у
цієї ситуації це навіть не назвеш
балансувати це правильно вести
себе знаєте ось мені не подобається дуже не
подобається фраза не можна всім допомогти я її
терпіти не можу вона дуже приречена мені
більше подобається коли я та інші говорять
я допоможу всім кому зможу ось усім кому
зможу щоб не через заперечення щоб ось
давати абсолютно відразу позитивну
спрямованість тому що ми робимо про що
ми думаємо як би там не було у будь-якій
ситуації
відливається не знається знають вони не буду
боятися та вішатися вина ціна спринтер
на спринтерські там забивати там 100
метрів xf це відривання насті батька
марафон три страви так залишайся і щось
там я там за 1 з порубаю я не спатиму
а ну і шоу долину зв'яжися в кармі будеш
там натиснути або карниз уббі будеш
допомагати до допомагати нікому величину
ніхто не знає, що нас чекає в майбутньому
зараз у клініці де я консультую
оффлайн консультую інших клініках там
вже є люди які вирвалися з пекла та
це абсолютно інша історія але проходить
час дасть Бог що ці люди
зберегти але у цих людях зберігається
ось це божа людська іскра яка
потім все одно розвивається в різні я
теж у своєму житті кілька разів бувала
ситуація коли ненароком що це не
останні мої хвилини просто тоді це
був дещо інший час але
відновлювалася тому поки що у
людини є життя і
знову ж таки я як психотерапевт і як
психолог знаючи ситуації коли людина не
може відновитися після травми
не може такі ситуації є на цій
приватної ситуації їм я не можу зараз на
їх говорити це суто професійна
моменту могла б якби у нас була а про
цьому розмова але він борги такі ситуації
бувають ніхто не знає що буде завтра
але поки що ми більш-менш знаходимося
більш-менш так він знає ось стан
коли можна підтримати себе та підтримати
іншого це потрібні ті варті сотні вдова
це націлено просто ось таку коробку
тому що цінно і важливо вишень я думаю
думка для багатого юля дуже дякую вам
цельсія кожен дуже читку попович як
раз клали налякав і можна брат її ти
жахливо до зустрічі та всього хорошого без
стійкого вечора мирної ночі на msi